NATO a Chronicle of Cruelty is the name
of this exhibition marking 70 years of
what the Museum's director calls the
most aggressive Alliance in modern
history
the inference here is that Ukraine is
NATO's fault for supplying weapons to
Ukrainian forces and supporting
nationalist battalions like azov placing
an American flag next door to an azov
Battalion flag is sufficient to prove
that NATO is supporting ministers
the idea that NATO is a defensive
Alliance is not the picture you'll get
here
as we leave a group of police Cadets
arrive the next generation of Russia's
security apparatus brought on message so
that NATO Remains the arch enemy
propaganda like this sinks in and it's
everywhere here on a nearby Street
photos of children from Donetsk and
luhansk subjected already to eight long
years of war protecting the people of
donbass one of the justifications for
Russia going into Ukraine drummed into
the national psyche at every opportunity
oh
countering that narrative is dangerous
Sasha scotchalenka who swapped grocery
tags in a supermarket for information on
civilian casualties in mariupole could
face up to 10 years in jail already more
than 600 people prosecuted for spreading
what the authorities deemed to be fake
news about the Russian Armed Forces
the Russian people have a well-honed
Instinct for oppressions burnt into them
during Soviet times which is why so many
people were so quick to leave the
country they understand the language
that Vladimir Putin uses of traitors and
scum and a fifth column All Too Well now
you're seeing the denunciations of
teachers by their pupils the expulsions
of students from universities the firing
of people from their jobs the shuttering
of Institutions that were meant to
encourage critical thinking that is the
domestic face of Russia's special
military operation but they're all Nina
begachova was expelled from her
University she thinks because of social
media posts supporting Ukraine I founded
out by accident when I couldn't log into
my Microsoft account
um and I called a Specialists from my
University and after maybe 30 maybe 40
minutes he calls me back and says well
unpleasant news there's a paperwork
inside of our system that you were
expelled two weeks ago I was not
expecting that
she says she wants people outside of
Russia to know that not everyone
supports what Russia is doing
but there are a lot of people who do who
don't really understand what's happening
but who believe that their presidents
the good guy because it's easier to
believe what they're told than it is to
accept the alternative
Donna McNeese Sky News Moscow